[Musique]
arrivée mouvementée sur l'aéroport de
nice côte d'azur cet après midi le
boeing 727 d'air france venait de se
poser à son bord mike connors plus connu
sous le nom de mannix
le héros du célèbre feuilleton est
aussitôt enlevé par un commando de
jolies filles conduit par l'actrice
danoise karine pedersen jeter dans une
cadillac qui démarre sur les chapeaux de
roues pour une mystérieuse destination
[Musique]
mais la voiture des ravisseurs et
brutalement stoppé les barrières de la
gendarmerie se ferment devant terre
mannix en profite
il s'échappe d'un bon félin franchi la
barrière sous les yeux consterné du
bataillon de charme qui s'est laissé
distancer de plusieurs longueurs
[Musique]
mais tout rentre bientôt dans l'ordre le
détective privé se retrouve sans sourire
pour distribuer des autographes
sous le regard attendri de son épouse
qui va le livrer aux photographes
le monde
[Musique]